the other thing i hate is spoiled
franchises
and it's been going on for a long time
it's a pre-social media thing i've
complained about this for a long time
don't tell me it's a certain franchise's
first title since 2010.
come on now yeah i'm going to hate that
i mean come on now like really there's
10 first titles since 2000
really really you got titles you got you
got teams that have never won titles
yeah
they've never been in the finals how
entitled
how entitled two titles
but you know what when you're the lakers
that's real
ten years is a lifetime in l.a and so
lebron is talking about how you know for
laker faithful
they don't care what you did before you
got here the lakers
they're like laker nation is like janet
jackson like what have you done for
me lately not lately what have you done
for me lately
it feels like nba seasons that do not
end with a laker title didn't happen
they just didn't have that if a
non-laker champion
is not a champion as far as they're
concerned it's like
two of them you can make it here there's
two of them celtics ain't quite
like that something except i don't i
don't think they're selling something
about the tie up tonight it's the same
number i'm not talking about the number
i don't find the boston fans
to be so elitist and that's saying
something about boston fans
i don't find them to be so excited that
they don't recognize
when another team wins a championship
this is what i'm saying
in new york you know in new york they're
saying is if you can make it here you
can make it anywhere
right in la it's if you haven't won
if you've won somewhere else it doesn't
matter until you've won here
like they don't if you have to do it as
a laker
to truly be considered great popular
arrogance it's different for them yeah
that arrogance and that elitism
it does exist with the celtics that's
why both of these franchises because
the lakers will win and i believe
they'll win tonight so that's 17 for the
lakers
17 for the celtics oh see look now
are we going into another conversation
you are dead right now michael you a
dead real no
i'll tell you what lakers lakers fans
view themselves
and their franchise as the crown jewel
of the nba
show themselves they have they are
well okay but okay but i'm saying i'm
not saying who's right they may think
they're the most successful franchises
but they don't view themselves
as as as the as the center point as the
epicenter of the nba away l.a yes they
do
yes they do okay look okay sure you know
you didn't
you lived there you lived there you
literally wrote the book
you literally wrote the book check it
out
but no i mean i really do i believe that
that
celtics fans see it the same way but
here's the difference and and
it's it's great that's why the celtics
lake lakers rivalry is one of the great
rivalries in sports
is that they both have an equal amount
of championships
but they approach it in different ways
so they both have this arrogance and hey
we're better than you are they both do
all right but the lakers
the lakers have actually had scoring
champs
you know the celtics have never had a
scoring champion and they're proud of it
they're like oh we're we do it the right
way we don't want a scoring champ
we want to play the complete game so
larry bird was never a scoring champ sam
jones none of them like paul pierce
never scored champ they don't want that
so i i think in la you know the
celebrities who were there
are from the the movie industry for a
lot of movies and music
boston celebrities are sports fans
like sports people yeah we've got
friends we got bill belichick
but it's still but it's still an
arrogance but it's east coast
celtics arrogance versus west coast
lakers there it's an arabic
it's an arrogance it's a it's an
arrogance like it's a boston new
york arrogance type thing or ba or or
almost like a defense mechanism
arrogance like again no disrespect to
what they've accomplished
but that's that's exactly what i'm
getting at like if it hits different in
la
hollywood second biggest market in the
country
okay yeah you know showtime showtime and
celtic pride just don't sound the same
okay it's the [ __ ] it's stars the stars
flock to l.a
courtside at a laker game the lakers
okay i live in connecticut i'm still in
new england
no i i think real they can be bill no
i'm gonna be i'm always keep for 100.
i'm always keeping 100.
always i don't know another way to be i
hold it down i keep it real that's my
job okay
um the lakers matter more
to the nba than the celtics i'm not
saying that the celtics
haven't mattered to the help co-author
nba history
they co-authored nba history right
alongside the
lakers i i am not ignorant enough to
suggest that the nba wouldn't be what it
is
without larry bird or without bill
russell before him
or red arbok of course but when you talk
about
the culture of the league let's call it
that all right when you talk about
you know who people would check for
nationally
nationally my stepdad was a laker fan
man
like my stepdad grew up rooting for
magic johnson you know
and and the culture war that was
showtime versus the celtics that was
magic versus larry
if you especially among black people
black america wrote with magic johnson
not larry bird
that's right and so what i'm saying the
nba if i know you say stop calling the
nba a black league
but if the nba is a black league black
people rolling with the lakers
i know it's not i know i know but i'm
just saying it's like the ruling with
the lakers not the celtics if
if i may bring that part of it into it
so again with all due respect to the
celtics and what they've done they have
the most championships
they have the greatest winner in team
sports history i'm not minimizing that
simply saying that culturally
and the lakers it's different which
makers are on top
well i said cultural nba culture nba
culture
it's different i don't know what it is
we're on top no that's different now if
if you're talking about um
if you're talking about black fans or
fans
about nba i'm just about the nba it's
about the nba well because it's because
the nba has
i would you know because because they're
both national teams and there
are there are fans in
remote places yeah not like 800 miles
from boston
who are something i love the celtics i
love the saltiness so and the same in
the same as for
the same is true of the lakers now if
you're talking about okay let's figure
out who their
those fans are they may have different
perspectives they may
look different so i agree with you there
but
i can't say across the board no question
you don't you don't you don't think the
lakers are a bigger brand
than the celtics it's like lakers it's
yankees
you know i think it's cowboys
i don't think the stop boys okay i mean
i can't
yeah i saw i'm not hating on the celtics
man i'm not i'm not daniel
i'm not
how are you thinking about it i'm just
making sure people no you think about
that you think about the twitter
warriors
you're worried about the twitter i think
i care about you you think i care about
twitter warriors
at this point in my life my career are
you you're arguing with somebody
who's not arguing with you he's like i'm
not saying
no i'm just making sure when i come
visit you in boston then i ain't got to
run up i ain't got to handle business
out in these streets i'm just but
i don't care about that either i'm
joking i'm honestly joking i'm i'm
saying
that i i i respect the celtics
and i don't want it to i don't want
anybody to misconstrue that's not how i
feel
i don't want anybody to miss what i'm
saying as it relates to the celtics
standing
in nba history it has mattered
right alongside the lakers i'm just
saying it's different when that lay is
on top
and that's why i get the whole since
2010. they feel like they're entitled to
it
they're the crown jewel flagship
franchise with all due respect to their
counterparts in boston
and the nba is how it feels to me no
it's amazing i mean you've got
um you're going to have 34
championships between these two these
two franchises
that's just wild and you think about uh
the legends who have been with both
franchises like both of them
it's hard to come up with an all-time
starting five
oh because you you're you're you're
leaving off
you're leaving up not only good players
you're leaving off hall of fame players
you need third you need third teams with
these two on the bench but they could
yeah i mean
think about and i'm saying this is the
the end-all be-all but think about
measurement stick but think about free
agency let's think about free agency
for a number of reasons for a number of
reasons
sure let's just put it that way for a
number of reasons
there's a boston in la or different
destinations shall we say
oh my god but there's some of it yeah
but some of it has to do with again the
pageantry
the flash again showtime hollywood some
that i think that adds to
you know what i'm talking about yes i
mean if you're when it comes to the
problem yeah if you're looking for
if you're looking for if you're looking
for that
yeah that's not just because that that
is
some of that is los angeles the city
some of that is the weather
i mean yes it is for a number of reasons
yeah there's
a lot of factors involved there yeah
you're not trying to you're not trying
to run the 25 degrees
with the uh real talk with the
windshield somebody who grew up in the
salt
i like the cold weather that's why i
stayed there my that's why i stayed in
my whole adult life i like the cold
weather i like it i like new way i like
the fall like the foliage
of new england i like i like boston
mike i've always lived in cold weather
cities and i'm still not used to it
you